welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and I can't wait to
play The Last of Us 2 on the PlayStation
4 now the controversy surrounding the
Last of Us part 2 just keeps getting
weirder and weirder and we're there and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it down after huge segments of
the game's storyline leaked two weeks
ago Naughty Dog in Sony have slowly gone
into a meltdown trying to cover
everything up and save face and it's
just phenomenal how badly that
everything's gone throughout this video
we'll be covering the fake reviews on
the game the copyright claims killing
dogs Game Stop pre-orders getting
canceled and a lot more there's a ton of
things to get through and there may be
some spoilers here so if you're the last
of us to spoil the game for yourself and
don't want anything rooms and I highly
suggest that you leave the video now if
you want to be kept up to date with the
story as it unfolds then make sure you
subscribe I'm sorry I'm laughing at how
bad these jokes are and please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy the video with
all out of the way though thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Naughty Dog's
damage-control okay so the first bit of
controversy centers around the copyright
claims put out by Naughty Dog in the
wake of leaks on the game Sony and their
partner filed several claims against
videos that used footage and images from
the leaks personally I actually think
that's fair enough
and if you use footage from unreleased
material you can indeed expect to have
the video taken down I've had that
happen myself with images from avengers
endgame the trailer for tin air and yeah
if they don't release it to the public
you don't really have much of a leg to
stand on however where this crossed into
the bad territory happened when they
started flagging channels for merely
talking about the leaks they even went
so far as to file a DMCA
against a twitter account called one
angry gamer because they made a meme on
the game using a character known as
senator armstrong from Metal Gear Rising
that is ridiculous especially because
the character doesn't even feature in
the Last of Us too and it was purely
done for satire purposes a lot of people
who receive claims fall back and within
the ten day period that is required
dispute a strike on YouTube they were
all thankful he dropped now Sonia
naughty dog have since denied putting
these claims out and have said that a
third party was responsible I'm not sure
if I believe this is the case just just
because it seems such a weird thing for
a stranger to do blocking the video
means that you can't make any money out
of it and in the past when scam channels
have done this they they tend to claim
the videos there's put adverts before it
and then get the money back from it it's
a practice that used to happen quite a
lot on YouTube but thankfully due to the
new way that claims are handled it
rarely does now
it also takes about 15 minutes I'd say
to file a DMCA and as there were
hundreds of videos being flagged either
someone was being paid by the company to
do it as a member of staff or someone is
just having a very very boring lockdown
I'll leave that up to you to make your
own mind up on it but yeah it seems very
obvious that Sony other ones is swinging
away here now the next bit of
controversy comes over the GameStop
description of the game on their
pre-order page originally in their
listing they posted the following
section one of the most noticeable new
features of the game is the inclusion of
dogs
these dogs are in the game to follow
your scent and will attack you as soon
as they have sniffed you out the game
doesn't pull any punches or stray from
the idea that why are you playing as
Ellie you'll have to fight the dogs in a
struggle to survive you also have to
deal with the fact that each dog has an
owner which will call out the dog's name
and cry in absolute horror when they
discover their lifeless very best friend
you've been warned wow this makes me
want to play the game so much it was a
really really weird way to advertise the
game and if you're someone that's ever
lost a dog you'll know it's not
something that you really want to sit
and do in a video game for fun our way I
forgot no a dog doesn't use the word fun
Noorie dog denied providing this text
but it still shows the direction that
the game is heading and it's difficult
not to find it a bit
I dunno stomach-turning seeing the
behind-the-scenes images of dogs in
mocap suits now it's a game at the end
of the day and you're not actually going
to be killing dogs but it has brought
more backlash to a game already
surrounded in controversy it just gets
worse and worse for Naughty Dog whether
they provided the text or not it's a
pretty weird thing to put in a game and
naturally the memes have come forth the
one that killed me the most was about
you having to kill a homeless person and
take a picture of it and then send it a
naughty dog in order to progress
hopefully that's with a golf club a lot
of free orders were canceled on top of
the pre-orders that had already been
cancelled so they had a big wave of them
that were canceled after the game was
delayed indefinitely further ones
canceled after the game leaked and then
after this gameplay mechanic came out
more were dropped Naughty Dog realizing
they'd be naughty about killing Naughty
Dog's had to clear everything up after
animal rights activists stepped forward
and said it was a bad thing to put in
the game since then Sony have released a
statement saying that you won't have to
kill dogs to finish the game but what an
utter shambles now not long after this
gamers started noticing strange things
on the PSN store in regards to the game
without even playing it over eight
hundred five star reviews had been
written personally I just find it a bit
unbelievable that that many people would
put positive reviews on the game without
playing it but we have seen something
similar to this that Sony has done
before
when death stranding was released it was
given over 6,000 negative reviews Sony
forced Metacritic to delete these
staying had been review bombed however
they didn't remove the positive reviews
for it that had also been spammed if
you're really promoting things fairly
then you need to remove positive review
bombing too and as the game isn't even
out yet and it has 800 positive reviews
already that shows something fishy is
going on so once more backlash came
forward and Naughty Dog and Sony are
clearly trying to do damage control at
this point the company can't really do
anything even their posts about things
like jak and daxter cosplay are getting
completely bombarded with memes on it
we're gonna be posting some now that
could spoil the game but these had be
absolutely dying so I
to share them it just shows that the
damage control they're doing isn't
working and it's just bringing more and
more attention to the game in a negative
way if they just said we're sorry the
game is leaked please be aware that this
isn't the entire thing then that would
be fine but it's just them doing weird
tactics like the DMCA memes disabling
likes and comments and videos and
putting fake reviews out there it's
purely because they try to limit the
backlash on this that it's completely
blown up in their face I'm still getting
the game to play and review it but it's
just been overshadowed by so much
rubbish that I'm not even excited to
play it anymore
now there's anyone that hasn't had it
spoiled for them and the plot just
sounds terrible let's be honest however
there is some light at the end of the
tunnel and Troy Baker aka Joel in the
game said the following in regards to
the leaks oh dude it doesn't matter look
if you think that the game can be ruined
by a couple of screenshots really a
studio with 30-plus years of development
with so many awards under their belt
they can't even put them all in one
trophy closet this is the biggest most
ambitious game they've ever done you
really think that that experience can be
undone by a couple of screenshots think
six years of development can be undone
by that it's a game it's a game you have
to experience it that's all I'm gonna
say so that does give me a little
glimmer of hope I don't know if I will
still enjoy it but at least the gameplay
will be good it's it's just the story
and those six little screenshots that
were designed to annoy people that I
have a problem with overall in the end I
would give the companies this advice if
you're in a hole stop digging if you're
playing golf and you've already lost
stop swinging little golf joke there it
just makes it so difficult to get behind
them and support this when they're
constantly handling things the wrong way
I was someone that at first avoided the
leaks then I read them got annoyed by it
calmed down then got angry again when I
saw all of the things that Sony were
doing this is not going to make people
who've cancelled their pre-orders put
them back in you've lost that audience
now and it will probably take a lot of
positive reviews and good word-of-mouth
win them back round if the game is that
good then it will get that however if
you're constantly trying to cover this
stuff up with the worst damage control
ever all you're gonna lead to is more
people canceling their pre-orders and
then you're gonna have to do damage
control to get them back and it's just
gonna keep ballooning until nobody wants
to play the game anymore
even I last week said I wouldn't be
reporting on the game any further
because the leaks were as bad as I
thought it was gonna get but it just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse
even within half an hour of making the
script for this video it started coming
out that a naughty dog employee has
called gamers chud's and began slamming
them and I just feel like the situation
is gonna get worse and worse for the
company this could end up being the
greatest game of all time but there's
gonna be such a sour taste in everyone's
mouth that it's gonna be hard to forget
it when you see a be doing a best Tiger
Woods impression I really wish we could
just jump ahead and get our hands on the
game and get it over with because it's
becoming such a car crash to see play
out hopefully it's not too long until
then
oh yeah what a swing and a Miss now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this situation so comment below and
let me know if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a thumbs up and if you
didn't see our last video on the leaks
then make sure you check it out after
this if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank-you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
Definition white tea or click the
discord link in the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people or subscribe to the channel and
this month you can win the Marvel phase
3 part 1 box set and all you have to do
is comment on a video and make sure you
serve with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen
tomorrow on the 15th of May so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
[Music]
[Music]
you